[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de paf la crise sanitaire pour
grave qu'elle soit ne rencontre pas que
des enjeux de santé le virus fait des
victimes il fait aussi comme disent les
militaires des des victimes collatérales
et parmi celles-ci certains territoires
et sans doute les moins favorisés mais
aussi des populations et
particulièrement les jeunes
c'est au nom de ces territoires de ces
populations que plus de 200 maires ont
lancé le 14 novembre dernier un appel au
gouvernement pour l'informer des
tendances lourdes de la crise alors deux
mois après cet appel et l'appel de
france urbaine qui regroupe les plus
grandes villes de france à aider les
populations les plus jeunes ou aux
sommes nous c'est la question de fond
posée dans ce numéro de paf avec un
studio arthur douanes bonjour bonjour
vous êtes haut fonctionnaire vous êtes
vous aider l'économie à sciences po et
vous êtes le fondateur d'une association
qui s'appelle l'équipe et qui aide les
jeunes des milieux défavorisés à l'est
notamment dans l'enseignement dans
l'apprentissage dans l'enseignement
supérieur avec nous sophie primas
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice des yvelines
vous êtes la présidente de la commission
des affaires économiques du sénat
catherine arenou vous êtes la merde de
jetons toutes les vignes et la
présidente aussi de hacktivity l'agencé
d'insertion des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
mais bonjour michel buisson vous êtes le
président de grand paris sud est et le
vrai ce président de cette association
qui regroupe beaucoup de grandes villes
qui est france urbaine
et puis jean philippe acensi bonjour
vous êtes de nouveau fondateur de
l'agencé pour l'éducation par le sport
alors sophie primas peut-être commencer
par vous vous avez reçu avec le
président larcher un certain nombre de
maires signataires de cet appel du du 14
novembre danse parlais à l'instant
qu'est ce qu'ils vous ont dit et qu'est
ce que vous leur avez dit bonjour à tous
d'abord ce qu'il nous dit cet appel
c'était un cri du coeur de mère qui ceux
qui sont j'allais dire face à des
situations qu'ils considèrent comme
étant dégradé de plus en plus dégradées
et surtout ce que ces mères nous ont dit
ce 2e était très actif très positifs et
qu'ils souhaitaient avoir quelques
moyens pour accompagner la politique de
rénovation urbaine dans l'eure dans leur
commune dans leur quartier et
l'accompagné donc pas par des grues mais
borloo le dis souvent les mains tendues
à ces populations sont dans ces
quartiers mais en plus du bâtiment en
plus des travaux de rénovation on a un
client besoin d'accompagnement de toutes
ces populations là sur tous les niveaux
du score même sport l'association
culturelle l'éducation elle on a besoin
en permanence d'accompagner ces
populations et ses accompagnements ont
besoin les ressources et ont besoin de
moyens voilà soixante mille eu à le dire
les maires et ce collectif n'est pas du
tout dans une posture revendicatrice et
s'est mis dans une posture constructive
et d'avenir et nous avons essayé dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2021 et
bien de concrétiser ses demandes au
moins sur certains postes
notre réussite n'a pas été totale c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire puisque
puisque ces budgets
lorsque ses revenus à l'assemblée
nationale n'ont pas été pérennisée
mais en revanche je pense que à la fois
le premier ministre mais aussi nadia et
ont compris que il fallait renouer le
dialogue avec ses nerfs renouer le
dialogue avec ces associations et
repartir sur une logique
d'accompagnement des populations parlent
du soutien financier dans ces quartiers
la pérennisation vous souhaitiez et que
souhaiter l'appel du 14 novembre c'était
que 1% du plan de relance soit soit
consacrée à ccc quartier c'est ça qu'on
fait sans vouloir faire de polémique
évidemment politicienne ici parce que
c'est pas l'objet c'était la promesse du
président de la république au bureau
donc le président de la république était
venu aux mureaux exprimé son soutien à
la fois je vous le redis sur la
rénovation urbaine mais aussi dans
l'accompagnement des populations et ça
s'est pas concrétisée dans le projet de
loi de finances donc je crois qu'on nous
annonce qu'il va y avoir de nouveaux
budgets déterminer ça veut dire qu'il y
aura des projets de loi rectificatif
et c'est la promesse du président de la
république donc et beaucoup d'espoirs
autour de cette promesse j'espère
qu'elle sera concrétisé et très vite si
on en a besoin
très vite parce que la situation je
pense cependant par leur art et est
inquiétante
justement 24e et red où je crois que
dans l'appel des maires du 14 novembre
12 vous êtes une des initiatrices
on parle de non assistance à un quartier
en danger est-ce que la situation alors
sanitaire qui évidemment perturbe la
france a été encore plus grave dans ces
quartiers problématique pour un objectif
alors c'est tout le problème de nos
quartiers
elle a était grave elle a été grave dès
le départ elle est à mes yeux d'autant
plus grave que malgré tous nos efforts
il ya moins prise de conscience de la
gravité sanitaire puisqu'il ya une
urgence sociale et économique
comment vous dire je pense qu'on
arrivera par exemple on est en train de
travailler avec les collègues d'à côté
sur la mise en place d'un lieu de
vaccination va l'aider à convaincre
petit à petit mais on a mis en place par
exemple des zones de pour faire des
prélèvements
nous n'avons pas le succès escompté sur
notre population parce qu'elle est au
coeur de ses préoccupations qui est
d'abord de manger ça a été une vraie
difficulté
je peux vous dire que les associations
qui font de l'humanité actuellement sont
absolument débordées le cc rsa
je lui ai fait je salue et on nous lui
avons donné 25 cents de plus sans
financement ça fait deux fois qu'ils
font des aides particulières à des à des
familles tellement les familles sont en
difficulté il ya tout un travail avec
les bailleurs pour essayer qu'il moindre
problématique dans le paiement des
loyers pape sinon les familles se crée
les problèmes se creuse
il ya eu en plus les bailleurs qui eux
mêmes ont donné des victuailles on en
est là dans nos quartiers actuellement
la première urgence à les spéciales et
les quasiment humanitaire on ne se rend
pas compte à quel point quand on a déjà
naturellement avant qu'il se passe rien
35% des habitants de la cité qui vivent
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
on ne se rend pas compte combien cela
sont explosées mais combien ce qu'ils
voient qu'ils vivaient sans trop
demander de dead sont devenus en grande
en grande grande difficulté et donc à
lot la situation a ajouté le problème
sanitaire
on sait qu' il n'est pas toujours et
médias parce que on a vu ben non plus
nos plus âgés je vais vous dire j'ai eu
dès les abords des taux de décès très
très important dans les deux premiers
mois du 1er confinement l'année dernière
nous avons énormément de personnes âgées
que nous suivons nous avons eu un
certain nombre de malades mais je pense
que c'est pas à la hauteur de nos
connaissances justement parce que nos
populations sont plus renfermés sur
leurs besoins élémentaires qui sont les
besoins de se nourrir
michel buisson fond ce mur ben
le mode beaucoup moins de deux villes de
mer vous êtes le vice-président à la
même analyse
oui oui tout à fait je crois qu'on l'a
on la partage au sein de toutes les
grandes métropoles et particulièrement
au sein de l'agglomération que j'ai le
plaisir de dany mais nous constatons
effectivement une montée évidemment la
pauvreté une montée des crudités à la
fois sur le français tanit et à
catherine 2010 mais aussi sur le plan
financier sur le plan budgétaire comme
sur le plan social pour vous donner un
exemple là où nous travaillons beaucoup
ce sont pour les populations des
étudiants qui sont profondément
évidemment toucher à la fois parce que
distants ciel pour tous les cours parce
que l'éloignement parce que perte de
sens évidemment par rapport à leur
propre formation et pour ceux qui sont
en résidence étudiants il y à un
isolement qui nécessitent un
accompagnement que nous avons d'ores et
déjà dense et déjà mis en place
donc oui et quartiers populaires
souffrent plus à la fois par rapport à
leur logement par rapport à leur type de
métier par rapport aussi à leurs
capacités et par rapport à la manière
dont il intègre les différents messages
de prévention donc oui il y en a
beaucoup plus de souffrance aujourd'hui
est vraisemblablement un vrai casse sur
le plan psychologique dans deux
quartiers populaires
justement vous parlez arthur donne
puisque ces jeunes je pense que le taux
de chômage chez les jeunes c'est 22 %
actuellement pas ce qu'est ce qui est
quand même assez effrayant alors ces 22
% en france en france mais ça n'existe
pour son offre
oui donc césar bien qu' il n'y a pas
forcément de fertilité mais pour
rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être dit moi
je suis saisi de voir que quinze ans
après le lancement de l'anru et alors
que cette année nous arrivons au terme
de la première en rue du premier
programme de nationalisations urbaine
celle agence nationale de réunions de
l'ado rénovation urbaine donc c'est
l'argent ce qui est effectivement chargé
d'accompagner la politique de la ville
du point de vue immobilier et du point
de vue urbanistique
moi je crois qu'il faut renverser la
logique c'est là qu'il faut pas une
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
il faut une nationale 1 agence nationale
des gens il faut accompagner les
personnes sophie primas l'a très bien
dit
et aujourd'hui effectivement peut-être
que les quartiers sont plus propres
peut-être qu'ils sont embellies
peut-être que les tours sur moins haute
mais les populations qui s'y trouvent
sont toujours les plus défavorisées de
france et donc si demain on veut aider
les populations qui sont les plus en
difficulté comme cela va falloir
forcément qu' il y ait des efforts
individuels qu'ils soient faits et pas
forcément de nature fiscale va falloir
que des gens accompagne individuellement
vers l'emploi accompagner
individuellement vers l'est vers les
études mais bref sorte de l'isolément
des gens qui suffoque dans leur
appartement ou vivent parfois plusieurs
et dans des appartements qui sont
beaucoup trop petit catherine r reno et
sophie primas d'ailleurs c'était un des
objets je croise de l'appel du 14
novembre de modifier leur rue pour que
il s'occupe pas seulement comme comme le
dit arthur donne des habitations ce qui
est important un mets qui s'occupe aussi
des populations d'asie catherine alors
pas vraiment pas vraiment à quoi ça peut
être ça peut être un véritable projet
qui est acquis et du coup d'envergure et
dans le long terme
ce qu'on demandait déjà c'est de donner
les moyens toutes les collectivités qui
était un projet de rénovation urbaine
d'abord d'avoir ce qu'on appelle la
clause de revoyure puisque vous savez
que les moyens étaient limités dès le
départ pour l'agent de rénovation
urbaine et qui a un certain nombre de
grands projets il y en a chez nous par
exemple mantes la jolie
il y avait un service de projets dont on
savait qu'il n'avait pas été accepté
dans leur totalité pas par pas parce
qu'on considérait qu'il n'était pas bon
mais bien par manque de boya donc ça
c'était là c'était le principe de la
revoyure nous ce qu'on demandait en plus
alors il a toujours été depuis longtemps
séparé le social actuellement c'est là
excepté le social du de l'urbain c'est
pas bien en soi mais si on change ça
s'éteint c'est un travail de à la fois
de long terme est d'importance ce qu'il
faut quand même c'est ne pas oublier la
au profit de l'autre faudra qu'il
faudrait que du coup leur cette
politique de la ville marche sur ses
deux jambes a essayé de gens c'est
l'accompagnement social éducatif sportif
culturel d'un côté l'accompagnement
urbano l'on peut pas réussir à vincent
l'ont tous ceux qui ont fait des plans
de rénovation urbaine le savent très
bien
on va parler du sport dans un instant
avec jean philippe acensi parce que
comme vous le disiez c'est très
important
certains quartiers mais justement je
reviens sur cette politique de la ville
au fond il ya eu jean louis borloo dont
vous avez fait partie de la vie de la
commission borloo et je pense que
beaucoup de ceux qui ont fait partie de
cette commission sont ont été un peu
choqué quand le président de la
république indique 75% du rapport avait
déjà été appliqué ce qui semble pas être
votre sentiment
mais cette politique de la ville au fond
depuis le temps qu'elle a lu est ce
qu'elle n'est pas quand même est-ce que
c'est pas quand même soldés par des
échecs
sophie primas puis à retire de la tête
sur ce sujet je vous regarder le verre à
moitié vide ou le verre à moitié plein
je pense qu on ne dira que c'est un
échec c'est dire que si on n'avait pas
fait cette politique on en sera au même
point moi c'est pas du tout ma
conviction je pense que si on a fait
cette politique
grâce à cette politique on a gardé des
quartiers j'allais dire en dessous ou au
dessus du niveau de flottaison dire que
les moyens d'accompagnement ont été
suffisants ou pour des années je ne le
crois pas dire qu'on a été assez vite
dans la politique de rénovation urbaine
on voit bien que dans les cinq six
dernières années la politique de
rénovation urbaine a quand même patiner
parce que ce qui avait été un formidable
élan sous jean louis borloo avec des
réalisations concrètes assez rapide
si tenté que la construction du c'est
rapide c'est quand même embourbé dans
les dernières années et on a du mal à
faire accélérer la fin de cette première
partie 2 est à faire repartir le nouveau
programme de rénovation urbaine avec
semblerait qu'aujourd'hui les choses
commencent à se décanter
mais il ya quand même eu toute une
période où on a un petit peu patiné une
période aussi vous n'a retiré des moyens
notamment collectivités territoriales et
en particulier aux municipalités je me
rappelle de catherine arenou lors d'une
visite qu'on a fait à chanteloup avec le
président larcher qui nous disaient mais
moi je suis au centime près vous obligé
de baisser les subventions à des
associations d'accompagnement
alors qu'on en a diablement au réseau
donc je pense qu'on stigmatise un petit
peu l'action de
rénovation urbaine et d'accompagnement
urbain ancien quartier d'al hasaba
finalement ça va pas si bien marché que
ça moi je pense que si on avait donné
les pleins feux ça marche
particulièrement bien et on sait très
bien que comme le disait catherine tout
à l'heure on a besoin à la fois de
pierre pour grues dans ces quartiers là
qu'ils sont le signe d'une rénovation
urbaine et d'un ou d'une attention à ces
quartiers là on a surtout besoin
d'accompagnement humain sur tous les
points de vue michel buisson sur sur
cette politique de la ville qu'est ce
qui a marché qu'est ce qu'il n'ya pas
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché il y à
d'excellents rapports qui a qui sortent
sur l'évaluation de la politique de la
ville et pour faire très court qui
disent la chose suivante est-ce que la
rénovation urbaine a fonctionné la
rénovation urbaine a fonctionné est ce
que les actions politiques de la ville
ont fonctionné elles sont aujourd'hui
impossible à évaluer
voilà donc je pense que ce 10e fille en
disant que intuitivement on sent bien
qu'elles ont apporté énormément de
choses mais la difficulté c'est
effectivement d'être capable de les
évaluer et de dire là où il faut faire
un peu plus
et là où il faudrait faire un peu moins
ce que je crois profondément c'est le
virage que l'on a engagé sur ce je crois
qu'il faut sortir de la dimension
politique de la ville pour aller vers
quelque chose que l'on pourrait appeler
l'inclusion là plusieurs républicaine
pour une raison simple il faut que l'on
joue collectif et qu'on arrête d'opposer
des quartiers populaires avec d'autres
quartiers plus aisés des quartiers
ruraux avec des quartiers de centralité
des quartiers de grand couronne avec des
quartiers de petit couronne tout ça il
nous faut faire république pour le dire
pour le dire pour le dire autrement
je pense aussi que il nous faut donc par
là même réinventer investi apte à
contribuer à réinventer ce récit
national collectif autour de la de la
république il nous faut en deux intégré
la transition écologique dans les
différentes actions que nous menons en
direction vol de nos de nos quartiers
populaires cette transition elle doit
être sociale si elle n'est pas social et
écologique sera antidémocratique et
c'est d'abord évidemment nos populations
les plus fragiles peuvent en bénéficier
et enfin il nous faut intégrer une
démarche qui soit beaucoup plus
empreinte de porosité parce que ce que
l'on considère est ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui à travers des chiffres très
précis c'est que par exemple dans mon
territoire 50 noms des personnes vivant
sous le seuil de pauvreté sont forts
quartiers prioritaires ce qui veut dire
que le sujet il est évidemment bien plus
large que celui comment dirais-je se
positionnant uniquement sur les
quartiers prioritaires et donc qu'ils
étaient les quais fac
quelles en seraient les leviers je pense
que c'est il me faut travailler sur la
méthode et la méthode
c'est ce que alors france urbaine dit à
plusieurs reprises mais ville et
banlieue tout autant c'est qu'il faut
redonner de la place du territoire et ce
sont aux territoires de piloter
l'ensemble de ces dispositifs la leurs
données en gros le la fonction
d'autorité organisatrice des politiques
publiques de de cohésion sociale de
manière à être en capacité de faire
beaucoup plus du c'ur du sur mesure
et puis il y a ensuite je crois deux
types de problématiques des
problématiques de nature je dirais
extrêmement extrêmement importantes qui
doivent être impérativement donc ce sont
des territoires en grande fragilité
parce qu'il ya des populations en grande
pauvreté
donc je cite un exemple et je le cite
sur mon territoire des villes comme
grigny par exemple et elle nécessite
d'avoir un pilotage porté par l'état
avec des opérations d'intérêt national
ou ce qu'on appelle d orco dit elle pour
les opérations de copropriétés dégradées
et ces quartiers là sont des quartiers
qui sont quand on dit la rénovation
urbaine n'a pas n'a pas porté ses fruits
moi je pense qu'il faut avoir
il faut avoir conscience que ces
quartiers sont des quartiers gare c'est
à dire ce sont des quartiers qui
accueillent des populations qui se sont
souvent des populations très modestes
souvent des populations étrangères et
que la mission de ces quartiers
en tous les cas peut-être n'évolueront
t-il d'ici 20 30 40 ans j'en sais rien
mais en tous les cas sur les 5 10 ans
qui viennent ce sont des ddd ce sont les
quartiers d'acteurs et de nos
populations en prime elle est plus les
plus modestes
il ya donc une mission nationale killer
qui leur revient et la rénovation
urbaine il est très important pour faire
en sorte que des habitants qui habitent
est envie de rester parce que la
difficulté est pourquoi ces quartiers de
l'art est toujours des quartiers pauvres
et que dès que les populations vont un
peu mieux évidemment elles suivent un
parcours et elle sort de ces quartiers
là c'est bien donc
et ça après tout pourquoi pas mais il
faut qu'on soit en capacité de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des habitants qui
avaient envie de rester et pour qu'ils
aient envie de rester
il faut effectivement qu'il y ait de la
rénovation de manière à ce qu'il y ait
plus de qualité de vie dans ces dans ces
quartiers justement ce maillage entre
les territoires et les pins dont on
parle beaucoup c'est un des grands c est
dès aujourd'hui
pourquoi ça fonctionne pas comme ça
devrait l'être acteurs de l'âne en fait
disons que c'est pas que ça fonctionne
pas je pense que simplement on s'est
peut-être trompé un peu d'objectifs
c'est à dire que pas trompé disons que à
l'origine la rénovation urbaine a été
construite pour attirer des populations
nouvelles on s'est dit on va reprendre
un peu la maxime de haussmann à est
réunifié embellir et ça va changer les
populations et créer de la mixité
de ce point de vue là il faut ça a été
dit par la cour des comptes il ya
quelques semaines ça n'a pas marché mais
à un moment donné il faut aussi
considérer que les gens qui habitent là
dans ce sont des êtres humains et que
embellir les lieux où ils habitent
rendre propre digne occupables habitable
des lieux qui sont insalubres en soit
c'est une réussite
c'est ça de la valeur de faire sentir
aux gens que oui on s'occupe d'eux et
que oui ils ont droit eux aussi
d'habiter dans des endroits qui sont qui
sont plus beau qu'avant parce que
effectivement quand on habite dans un
endroit qui est en lady sur pour
l'estimé de soi c'est c'est calamiteux
si vous voulez voilà c'est plus agréable
de vivre dans un hôtel particulier facal
imagine bien que dans une tour de 30
étages et la rénovation urbaine c'était
une façon de redonner de la dignité en
embellissant le bâti donc ça pour moi
c'est une réussite
maintenant la houle
pense que le rapport borloo a eu une
faille c'est que c'était encore un plan
à 50 milliards et que la politique de la
ville aujourd'hui
bon an mal an c'est à peu près une
dizaine de milliards pas toujours placée
là où il faut c'est certain mais on peut
pas si vous voulez on peut pas arriver
et dire simplement qu'on va doubler le
coût de la politique de la ville par an
parce que en fait ça donne ça donne le
bâton pour se faire battre à ce moment
là c'est pour ça que je crois que
vraiment ce qu'on se côtoie pouvoir
réussir à faire c'est d'imaginer une
sorte d' agences nationales d'égalité
des chances entre les territoires
partout sur le territoire ça a été très
bien dit tout à l'heure il faut arrêter
de segmenter banlieue réalité parce
qu'en fait l'archipel français est déjà
dans cette distinction est donc avec
cette agence là je pense qu'il va
falloir mobiliser toutes les forces qui
existent les entreprises les grands
groupes les startups des élèves de
grandes écoles pour accompagner aller
les cent mille jeunes qui pose problème
aujourd'hui en france parce que dans le
fond dans les 150 quartiers qui sont
vraiment les plus les plus durs les plus
en rupture il ya à peu près cent mille
jeunes pour la république qui sont
vraiment vraiment vraiment en situation
de décrochage scolaire était même de
décrochage personnel et pardon d'être
aussi cru mais c'est forcément dans ces
cent mille jeunes si vous voulez que se
recrutent ensuite les jeunes qui
s'islamise rond d'avantagés qui se
mettront vraiment en lutte contre la
france et contre la république
sophie primas ce que ce que dit arthur
de nos fonds de l'indh et des fous qu'on
pouvait trouver au plan borloo c'est
qu'ils coûtent très cher et catherine
arenou aussi là dessus c'est votre
sentiment
de ce que coûte pour la société le fait
de laisser tomber une partie des
habitants de nos villes ont fait jamais
ce ratio là on fait jamais ce ratio là
et pourtant il est terrible parce qu'on
emmène dans la pauvreté et à l'aise dans
la pauvreté et dans la détresse et dans
la perméabilité ça vient d'être dit à
certaines thèses qui sont anti
républicaine on laisse une partie de la
population de côté et je crois que
j'apprécie faut 50 milliards si l'info
40 il en faut 30 en tout cas il faut
mettre des moyens au service de ces
populations là pour les réintégrer
moi je voudrais juste dire que je
partage totalement le point de vue de
michel buisson alors lorsqu'il parle du
cloisonnement de nos politiques
publiques qui amène à cloisonnement de
la population je pense que depuis très
longtemps depuis peut-être 40 50 ans
maintenant vous faites des politiques
publiques en tuyaux pour des populations
pour des quartiers pour des lieux et en
fait on s'intéresse pas aux gens et je
pense que ces politiques publiques en
tuyaux elles ont mené à cet archipel de
la population qui se retrouvent non plus
côte-à-côte aujourd'hui mais comme le
disait à l'époque ministre de
l'intérieur partant face à face et je je
je crois qu'effectivement il faut
repenser la politique d'aménagement du
territoire de façon décentralisée mais
en ayant une vision beaucoup plus
holistique alors oui il faut remettre de
l'argent dans ces quartiers là où il
faut continuer la politique de
rénovation urbaine parce que ce sont des
signaux de considération vis-à-vis de
ces populations qui sont importants oui
il faut mettre des moyens je pas si
c'est 50 milliards en tout cas pour
mettre plus de moyens qu'aujourd'hui non
pas sur une politique publique ciblée
sur des quartiers mais sur une politique
publique qu'ils soient ciblées sur des
populations qui en ont besoin
quel que soit l'endroit où elle habite
on oppose trop souvent les pauvres de la
ville ou pauvre de la ruralité
on le les jeunes qui ne trouvent pas de
travail dans les quartiers et ceux qui
ne trouvent pas de travail pour d'autres
raisons
dans les campagnes dans les zones
périurbaines donc vraiment je crois
qu'il est temps de changer de
de façon de regarder la france et de
regarder les français d'en bas les bouts
de france parce que ça ça mène à une
archi lisation de la population qui est
me semble-t-il assez vengeance 4 nra zo
je me suis trompé en effet tout à
l'heure quand je disais que c'était
l'appel du 14 novembre qui qui demandait
qui est une rénovation à la fois d'aider
des bâtiments mais aussi des habitants
c'est un rapport pardon de l'institut
montaigne et dans ce rapport on
considère comme un atout justement le
fait que les populations ne reste pas
très longtemps dans les quartiers aidé
par la politique de la ville pour aller
vite et ce transfert dans d'autres
quartiers dès qu'ils le peuvent et
disent au fond qui cette mobilité est
plutôt un atout
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous pensé qu'il vaudrait mieux
avoir des quartiers dans lesquels des
gens peuvent rester parce qu'il les
trouve beaux comme déserteur de rome où
il que cette mobilité finalement un
atout paf à la vraie question
la vraie question c'est qu'il soit libre
c'est qu'il soit libre comme l'ensemble
des habitants de france
dire que quand on habite dans un
quartier populaire on doit avoir la
possibilité d'en sortir ou d'y rester
selon son propre choix
or actuellement et je vais ouvrir sur
deux sujets le premier sujet c'est
comment on évalue la politique de la
ville on n'arrête pas de l'évaluer par
rapport à un territoire
alors qu'il faut l'évaluer par rapport à
des habitants c'est comment en ayant
accompagné telle famille qui était en
difficulté qui sort des difficultés pour
aller vers ici ouvert ailleurs comment
ces politiques là ont-elles contribué à
une réussite donc individuel familial et
non pas une réussite de territoire
pourquoi mais parce que entre temps on
vous l'a dit quand les gens commencent à
aller bien
ils ont du coup ça leur crée un peu de
liberté s'est alors créé la possibilité
de partir de ce territoire et ils sont
remplacés par des plus précaires encore
c'est la vraie problématique de nos
territoires
depuis quarante ans maintenant c'est pas
qu'il y ait des gens plus pauvres - port
c'est qu'ils sont plus nombreux et plus
pauvres dans nos quartiers et quand ils
vont mieux sont remplacés par toujours
des gens plus précaires vous n'avez qu'à
regarder tous les deux les portraits de
quartiers qui sont faits depuis trois
quatre ans là dans le dernier truc
politique de la ville comptera politique
de la ville on voit qu'en fait toutes
ces quartiers c'est plus les mêmes
qu'ils habits qu'ils y habitent
ils sont moins nombreux dans chaque
quartier mais l'amour
les plus pauvres donc ça veut bien dire
une chose c'est qu'on continue en fait
avec le staff de solidarité de nos
populations et je voudrais qu'on pense à
un truc et qui est une évidence pour nos
quartiers comme dans des dents des vies
vous avez 40 à 45 % de logements sociaux
en plus des logements sociaux concentré
ce sont des lieux sur lesquels les gens
n'ont pas choisi de venir surtout en ile
de france
on leur a attribué ces logements ils
sont trop contents de le saisir qu'ils
soient du secteur qui faisait de la
famille qui la travaillent dans le point
peu importe l'essentiel c'est de méthane
toit sur la tête de ses enfants est donc
pratiquement tous les habitants de nos
logements sociaux même si ça devient de
moins en moins vrai là où il ya eu une
belle rénovation urbaine mais la plupart
des habitants de logements sociaux ne
sont pas des gens libres de venir et ne
sont pas non plus les genres des gens
libres de partir et ça ça changera tout
quand on aura réussi à leur donner une
telle autonomie par les moyens de la
politique de la vie qu'ils puissent
rester qu'ils puissent contribuer à
faire la réussite de nos quartiers il ya
une chose qui est assez intéressante
michel buisson vous êtes membre du parti
socialiste
sophie primas et membre de 2,2 le de l
heure est au fond vous avez les mêmes
analyses sur ces sur ces questions alors
quand on se dit que voilà c'est pas une
question de deux partisans politiques
on se demande comment on n'arrive pas à
trouver quand même tous ensemble des
solutions plus concrètes pour pour
justement pour ces territoires et pour
la politique de la ville alors que vous
êtes d'accord sur les sur les constats
posés la question michel bissonnet est
allé jeudi
voilà pardon je disais je disais sur
livret masse qui est intéressant c'est
que sur les constats michel buisson qui
est du ps vous qui êtes l air vous êtes
d'accord
donc on se dit que si un accord
politique et que ce sont des problèmes
qui le dépasse en effet les les
querelles partisanes
comment on n'arrive pas à avoir une
politique sur laquelle tout le monde se
mette autour d'une table et et soient
d'accord puisque vous avez les mêmes
constats c'est une vraie question c'est
une vraie bonne question
c'est une vraie bonne question parce que
en effet sur ce sujet il ya d accord
trans partisan qui sont pas très nouveau
en réalité on a beaucoup de maires et
voilà le mouvement qui est porté par
catherine par d'autres également
il est bien connu il il réunit des
maires de communes avec des étiquettes
politiques extrêmement variées qui vont
du parti communiste puisque enfin la
droite il ya on n'arrive pas à avancer
probablement pour des questions de
cloisonnement trop important de sophie
primas je crois qu'on a perdu votre son
michel bissonnette est d'accord qu'ils
aient sophie et surtout j'imagine
surtout la partie qu'on entendait moins
bien mais oui je pense que là il y a
plusieurs dimensions maintenant qui
permettent d'analyser des
positionnements politiques la gauche la
droite en est un l'écologie punitive ou
l'écologie plus comment dirais je a cité
on est en est une autre
l'europe ou pas l'europe en voilà une
troisième et puis là la dimension
territoriale est évidemment quelque
chose qui nous qui nous rapproche parce
que les les difficultés qu'on rencontre
dans une commune quelle que soit la
couleur politique du maire sont des
difficultés qui sont de même de même
nature donc on se rejoint assez assez
rapidement sur sur les constats et donc
sur les solutions l'a bien vu sur
l'appel du 14
novembre au labo beaucoup d'élus de
toutes couleurs politiques l'ont loin
l'ont portée et puis pour ce qui
concerne la france urbaine ya évidemment
des élus de toute coloration politiques
de toutes sensibilités politiques et qui
porte le fait de contractualiser à
l'échelle des territoires pour régler
ces sujets là ce que ce que je crois
c'est que là la question elle est encore
une fois une question méthodologique est
une question de de meilleure définition
de la chaîne de l'action publique en
france qui aujourd'hui ne fonctionne
plus ont tous les cas ne fonctionne ne
fonctionne pas bien on le voit sur cette
crise sanitaire avec évidemment toutes
les incertitudes qui pèsent sur à la
fois le virus et la manière est
évidemment de trouver de trouver
solution mais le fait de ne pas avoir
une approche globale qui intègre
l'ensemble des dimensions l'ensemble des
parties prenantes par exemple tout
simplement intégrer des élus non pas
pour décider mais pour préparer la
décision
si un élu avait été intégrée dans la
préparation de décision le jour où on
avait dit qu'il fallait fermer les
commerces de proximité on aurait levé la
main immédiatement en disant mais fermer
les commerces de proximité sur les
séquences surface ça va créer un petit
problème et donc cela aurait été
anticipée bref il ya besoin d'une autre
manière de construire la décision en
france pour pour ce qui concerne l'état
mais je pense qu'il faut que l'état
arrête de penser la pause ils lalalalala
comment dirais-je la politique de la
ville elle doit être d'inclusion
républicaine et préalablement
d'inspiration territoriale nous avons
eues durant les trente glorieuses
un état qui était un état dirigeants et
ça a fonctionné on a eu dans les années
90 un état stratège s'est construit sur
le mode du des entreprises privées sais
pas si ça a fonctionné en tout cas ça eu
quelques vertus et aujourd'hui on est
toujours sur ce mode là et ce mode là
est aujourd'hui totalement dépassé
ce dont nous avons besoin c'est d'un mac
ou d'un état qui soit d'état
accompagnant
avec airplay verticalité pour assurer
sur les sujets dont on parle
la cohésion sociale donc laissons ce
territoire par rapport à leur propre
indicateur de fragilité définir les
politiques publiques qu'elles soient et
de rénovation urbaine éducative emploi
sport culture de manière à fixer ses
propres priorités et d'être accompagné
évidemment par l'état mais par l'état
droit commun par l'état droit commun là
où il y a nécessité donc silica sur le
plan éducatif des fragilités qui sont
notés sur un certain nombre de familles
positionner sur un certain nombre de
groupes scolaires et malawi il faut
certainement doubler les enseignants
comme ça se fait sur un certain nombre
de deux classes mais mais mais ayons une
approche territoriale qui permet un
ajustement du but qui permet cette fort
audités entre des quartiers permet de
n'exclure personne d'une pop de ne pas
pointer du doigt les quartiers
prioritaires et de ne pas pointer ce que
vous ferez pas prioritaire est donc
surtout n'ont pas envie d'aller dans des
quartiers prioritaires
bref on y est et non une démarche qui
soit comme beaucoup plus républicaine
jean philippe acensi pardon je crois que
vous nous entendez on ne vous voit pas
de vous nous entendez un oui c'est ça
alors justement parlons de cette agence
pour l'éducation par le sport on va
parler et justement vrai le volet de la
jeunesse qui autre volet important
revenons donc en quoi le sport est il un
facteur d'insertion pourquoi vous avez
eu l'idée de fo 17 de cette fondation
bah écoutez si vous entendez les maires
tous vous diront que le sport c'est à la
fois les plus grandes associations qui
mobilise le plus de jeunes et qu elles
sont implantées dans l'ensemble des des
quartiers français et que le sport joue
un rôle beaucoup plus important que
l'aspect compétitif
c'est un acteur d'inclusion c'est un
acteur de lien social
c'est un acteur de mixité sociale où
finalement
l'apprentissage qu'on donne dans un club
de sport
globalement c'est de savoir travailler
collectivement de savoir se fixer des
objectifs voilà un tas de valeur qui
hélas ne sont pas assez reconnus ne sont
pas assez reconnus aujourd'hui en france
donc nous on a eu cette idée de se dire
fort du potentiel que l'on a eu ces
vingt dernières années de repérer des
des associations à ses modèles de dire
voilà comment faire le lien finalement
avec l'entreprise parce que ça y est on
a deux jeunes femmes
pendant ce temps des fêtes vous c'est le
lien entre le sport et l'entreprise
aussi exactement c'est à dire que on a 2
million de jeunes au chômage sans
diplôme en france qui ce qui est quand
même très alarmant le monsieur de
sciences po disait il faut privilégier
il faut recentrer l'action sur le ter
200 villes jeunes le sport est en
capacité justement de faire ce lien
entre eux entre le sport et l'entreprise
est en fait le métier qu'on a qu'on a
créé coach d'insertion par le sport
qu'on met en place chez madame arenou et
à roubaix à marseille dans d'autres
villes françaises
c'est de dire que c'est un métier
d'insertion professionnelle où on va
chercher les jeunes des clubs et on leur
propose un parcours qui peut faire le
lien avec les entreprises par exemple
avec le crédit agricole on a on a permis
à 300 jeunes de deux d'intégrer intégré
l'entreprise en faisant ce lien en
préparant ces jeunes qui ont des valeurs
qui qui sont motivés à rentrer dans
l'entreprise
et ça fonctionne maintenant il faudrait
essayer de le développer un peu partout
dans dans dans ces quartiers difficiles
et est ce que la situation actuelle
alain avec justement la fermeture des
clubs des clubs sportifs vous la jugez
justement difficile pour ne pas dire
dramatique
bien évidemment je vais dire elle est
dramatique parce que enfin dans un club
de sport pour voir prioritairement ses
amis on va dans un club de sport pour
pour fraterniser
on va simplement un club de sport pour
faire de la compétition ce sont des
lieux des lieux de vie des lieux de joie
donc on pense qu'il faut reconsidérer la
fermeture de ces lieux parce que les les
dégâts les dégâts en termes de lien
social sont immenses donc effectivement
que la fermeture des lieux sportifs dans
nos quartiers mais même ailleurs état
est un vrai drame quoi partir douarnenez
le monsieur de sciences po justement là
l'équipe et qui aide les jeunes à
accéder des jeunes de quartiers
défavorisés accéder à notamment à
l'enseignement supérieur mais aussi à
l'apprentissage est ce que vous pensez
que la jeunesse au fond est la vraie
victime de deux de la situation actuelle
et peut-être de ces politiques un peu
erratique qui ont été menées de la ville
de vin notamment victime c'est peut-être
enterrement un peu fort
ce que je constate comme vous c'est
qu'il ya un consensus autour du plateau
sur l'idée qu'il faut aider les
habitants plutôt que les bâtiments en
tout cas pas que les bâtiments
parce que dans le fond et c'était ça
aussi l'intuition de l'équipe et c'est
qui a aujourd'hui 3 jeunesse en france
qui ne se parlent plus il ya la jeunesse
des grandes villes des beaux quartiers
qui vit sa vie qu'il ya ces lieux de
sociabilité propre la jeunesse des
quartiers qui a aussi ses lieux de
sociabilité ces moments à elle sa vie à
elle et la jeunesse des zones rurales et
elles vivent aujourd'hui dans des
solitudes conjointe de 1880 à 1980 on a
eu un modèle on a eu bien sûr des
événements tragiques du 20e siècle mais
on a eu un modèle qui a tenu bon autant
que possible qu'est la république et qui
mélangeait tous ces jeunes autour de
creuset républicain jean fau
jean-philippe à son psy lui ou par
l'insertion par le sport dans le fond
c'était l'un des creusets républicain
absolument c'était le creuset des
loisirs alors il y avait le sport il y
avait les colonies de vacances
l'éducation populaire sas en était un
l'école les usines et puis le service
militaire je crois pour aller vraiment à
l'essentiel et pour essayer de se donner
collectivement une vision qui pourrait
être celle d'une france unie à partir de
là c'est de rebâtir ses quatre creuset
républicain et c'est ça la grande
politique dont le fonds qui est pas
seulement une politique de la vie
l'amérique est une politique de la
nation catherine arenou justement le
problème de la jeunesse dans une ville
comme chanteloup c'est un problème au
coude en activité puisque c'est d'eux
s'est associé au d'insertion des jeunes
c'est un problème essentiel pour vous à
vos yeux ah bah oui la jeunesse par
nature c'est celle qui sait ce sont les
adultes de demain pour venir surtout
d'ailleurs dont on a parlé du sport on
se rend pas bien compte encore mais on
on commence à avoir les premiers retours
de nos toutes petites associations
sportives sauver traditionnellement dans
le quartier il ya le foot la boxe qui
marche assez bien parce que là il ya
beaucoup d'adhérents et bien après on a
depuis dix ou vingt ans tous ceux
contribué à faire venir tous les autres
sports les sports qui étaient censés
être les mois les moins attractif pour
nos populations qui le sont devenus mes
services des toutes petites associations
sportifs
elles vivent avec très peu de sous leur
seule leur seule preuve le gros
financeur c'est toujours la ville avec
les avec les adhésions
elles ont pratiquement de chez moi ils
ont perdu 3 35% d'adhésion en moins en
septembre 2020 par rapport aux septembre
2019 et ceux qui sont restés commencent
à demander le remboursement de leurs de
leur licence ça veut dire qu'en fait ces
associations là qu'on est en train de
voir là entre roman au fait le budget
elles sont toutes en train de nous dire
oh on lâche la faire car on arrête c'est
trop compliqué financièrement c'est trop
compliqué le président veut plus prendre
ça sur ses épaules
donc en fait j'ai l'impression et
s'habille pas rien j'ai l'impression
dans certains territoires comme les
notes du coup avec la grande fragilité
pis et puis le fait que nos gamins quand
ils sont pas dans du sport et qui vivent
pas comme ça de la mixité aussi parce
que du coup il se mélange avec d'autres
villes est tout bête tout bêtement ils
sont désespérés un peu chez eux donc ils
sont de nouveau un peu plus dans la rue
j'ai l'impression qu'on fait
pratiquement dix à quinze ans en arrière
à l'époque on avait essayé de
réintroduire tout un tas de sports
différents pour donner à nos jeunes les
mêmes chances qu ailleurs chance qu'on
essaie de leur donner à la culture mais
qu'on essaye de leurs données par
justement c'est le mélange ou ses envies
de faire des sports différents
et puis parce que ça développe aussi
hélas jean philippe l'a dit ça
développe aussi tout un tas de
compétences que le jeune a en lui
naturellement mais qu'il n'arrive pas à
trouver tout seul donc ça veut dire que
dans nos quartiers cette situation
sanitaire qui entraîne la fermeture des
clubs sportifs et des clubs sportifs
entre autres vers les plus jeunes alors
qu'on n'est pas dans la notion de
compétition sportive et de réussite avec
des médailles
ça va être je pense un peu plus grave
qu'ailleurs et on revienne pas est
pratiquement il ya une année scolaire
donc une année sportive de passer nous
notre idée c'est de dire comment on va
pouvoir atteindre septembre 2021 add-on
ces fameux giro qui vont être développés
en ile de france
et comme on est gamin du quartier ne
vaut pas encore regardé mes balades par
exemple le score au niveau olympique
l'an passé devant les yeux sans qu'ils y
participent
jean philippe acensi dont quand il ya eu
le discours des bureaux du président
emmanuel macron évidemment il ya le
sport qui est générateur de valeur qui
est générateur d'insertion dans
l'entreprise et ce c'est ce que vous
faites avec l'agencé pour l'éducation
par le sport mais on a aussi parlé de
certains clubs qui use ce produit des
radicalisations est ce que c'est un
phénomène important à votre sens
et comment lutter contre ce phénomène
peut-être qu'il n'est plus à philippe
acensi alors je pose de poser la
question avec catherine arenou à la
redoutable
j'avais coupé pendant micro de chiffres
très imprécis sur le sujet il faut
prendre en considération ce problème là
les clubs de sport font partie de la
panoplie du du prosélytisme religieux si
je puis dire parce que parce
qu'évidemment les clubs de sport c'est
c'est d'une capacité gigantesque vous
allez vous allez attrape le club de
football ces 1500 adhérents
donc ça veut dire que ton ciel à de
captation des jeunes est gigantesque
c'est pour ça qu'il faut essayer de
nous accompagner qu'à tribunaux disait
il ya un déficit d'accompagnement ne
sait que le kent qui est phénoménal à la
fois en termes d'indicateurs mais aussi
un génie pour monter des projets parfois
le gouvernement nous dit il faut
utiliser les fonds européens faut mieux
utiliser les fonds sur l'investissement
des compétences mais ces dossiers sont
extrêmement lourds et vous savez les
clubs de sport sont surtout dans une
culture de du projet de l'action un club
de sport sa vie tout le temps c'est des
entraînements et on est beaucoup moins
sûre le sur le montage des dossiers
et c'est là il faut vraiment accompagner
dans les villes il faut des nouveaux
métiers
il faut structurer le champ sportif il
faut des nouveaux métiers sur
l'accompagnement et le développement des
projets parce que y'a su potentiel
énorme et ce risque que vous pointez il
est réel il faut il faut mieux mesurer
mais évidemment que 1 malheureusement ce
sont des des proies
si je puis dire très importante pour des
gens malveillants parce que avec le
sport cents à un succès énorme et pas
simplement pas simplement les clubs de
foot aujourd'hui dans les quartiers vous
avez vous avez des pratiques urbaines
qui font un travail extraordinaire où là
aussi on permet à des centaines de deux
jeunes d'être accompagné exemplaire
belle initiative développée par parcours
c'est l'art du déplacement
il ya où il ya un vrai travail avec les
jeunes donc il ya un potentiel énorme
mais aujourd'hui folle aux structures et
je terminerai en disant les les locaux
sont montés au créneau dernièrement pour
dire voilà un des angles morts du plan
de relance
c'étaient les clubs amateurs il faut
faire quelque chose d'urgence pour ces
clubs qui sont à deux doigts d'arrêter
l'activité ça serait dramatique
dramatique pour un certain nombre de
deux collectivités qui s'appuie sur ces
clubs pour accompagner cette jeunesse
partir de l'industrie
est ce que dans
ou alors c'est plutôt vers l'éducation
vous avez des jeunes on sait qu'il ya la
crise actuellement dans les universités
avec les étudiants évidemment la période
est pas très difficile mais est-ce qu'il
ya quand même désespoir
ce couple et c'est sur ce que disait
jean philippe acensi parce que en fait
si vous voulez vraiment pour lutter
contre la radicalisation commentaires le
discours sécuritaire et tout son arsenal
je ne peux pas suffire il ya un besoin
de tous et de tous ces jeunes des
quartiers de de voir autre chose que
leur quartier parce que s'il est seul à
s'occuper de son les phares musulmans ou
les ou des salafistes du quartier dans
ce cas là c'est series et et qui sont
très organisés et qu'ils sont
intellectuellement bien plus structurée
con qu'on veut bien le croire
et donc un besoin de voir autre chose et
un besoin de reconnaissance sur le
besoin de voir autre chose
il ya une histoire qu'on a vécu avec
l'équipe est qui et qui est à mon avis
un désespoir que vous évoquez on a eu à
s'occuper d'une fille voilée par voile
intégral bien sûr mais qui refusait de
serrer la main de son mentor de donc du
jeune qui l'accompagnait qui refusaient
qui lui paye même le café lorsqu'il
lorsque l'on n'avait le droit de prendre
du café à l'époque est à la fin s'ils
voulaient à force d'être en confiance à
force de s'ouvrir à force de changer
d'environnement
à force d'aller à la fac à la fac
d'anglais à nanterre où elle a pu aller
etc afin de changer complètement
à la fin il a fini par enlever le voile
voilà et je dis pas que c'est là le
grand objectif donc on doit se donner de
dévoiler toutes les femmes de france
parce que je veux dire mais bien
d'envoyer sa part c'est bien c'est que
ça marche comme ça va lâcher si on les
exhume à cela la fréquentation doute
l'ouverture à d'autres en venant de la
main mettre en confiance et faire
comprendre que oui on est les bienvenus
parce que c'est le sujet de la
reconnaissance et à dire que à défaut de
voir autre chose on veut être reconnu et
donc on se sert du vol comme une façon
de se montrer et de dire j'existe
et de ce point de vue là il s'agit pas
de battre sa coulpe ou de déboulonner
des statuts il ya le tout de même
quelques événements historiques dans
l'histoire de france qui reste comme des
frustrations historique dans l'identité
des jeunes des quartiers
par exemple vous voyez au moment de la
libération de la france en
44 45 quand les troupes française défile
sur les champs elysées et
qu'effectivement ordre avait été donné
que les tirailleurs sénégalais n'avait
il pas que les tabors marocains qui
avaient joué un rôle décisif dans la
bataille de monte cassino en corse nous
de simba et c'est pour ça que vous avez
parfois des jeunes qui vous disent
maintenant que mon grand père il était
dans les sérails à mon grand père il
était dans les tabors marocains est
plutôt que d'en faire un motif de fierté
vous enfants motif de reproches parce
que c'est encore ça et donc square était
exactement dans le froid que au lieu de
déboulonner il va falloir re boulonné
c'est à dire montrer ce que tous les
tous les gens qui ont des origines
africaines ou maghrébines tout ce que
leur sincérité on fait voilà on fait
pour la france et en faire justement
faire de leur place ici un motif de
fierté nationale justement ben yahia
quand même un petit peu d'espoir michel
buisson france urbaine justement insiste
sur la nécessité d'aider les jeunes de
dire que voilà c'est là c'est là que ça
se joue
ouais ouais mini tout à fait je
considère fâchent parce qu'il faut qu'on
considère que la jeunesse est une
richesse et ses excès évidemment il y
compris qu'ils peuvent être très graves
donc cela il faut évidemment les réguler
mais les teckels et le département en
france où il y a le plus de créations et
de plus de création d'entreprise c'est
la scène samedi à la fois les
départements qui ont le plus de
fragilités qui ont aussi le plus de
capacité d'innovation et qui comporte
énormément de jeunes donc il y a je
dirais énormément de capacité à faire de
capacité d'imagination danser dans ces
quartiers-là mois les les les plus
belles innovations sur notre territoire
que j'ai vu émane de grigny c'est-à-dire
là où il y a peut-être les plus grosses
difficultés il ya aussi la plus grosse
capacité à imaginer à imaginer des
solutions et le rôle qu'y et qui est le
nôtre c'est évidemment d'embarquer nos
jeunes sur le chemin de l'enthousiasmé
pas sur le chemin de 2,2 de l'inquiétude
il ya mille raisons pour être inquiet
locaux vides en étain et frappe
évidemment immanquablement les jeunes
plus que d'autres
il y a évidemment ce réchauffement
climatique et les jeunes sont nés avec
cela en tâche de fond et c'est
évidemment profondément inquiétant mais
le rôle qui est le nôtre et le rôle de
nos politiques publiques c'est de les
mettre sur le chemin de l'enthousiaste
parce que eux avec la lecture qu'ils ont
du monde ils ne sont pas imprégnés de
notre récit du progrès permanent voilà
moi à mon âge il ya un respect qui m'a
conduit là où je suis avec un progrès
permanent mais dans un monde où les
ressources sont finis c'est évidemment
juste impossible et il nous faut trouver
des solutions mais on a bien du mal à
les trouver parce que c'est il nous
faudrait sortir je dirais de notre
confort et ça c'est quand même pas le
plus évident même si on est tous
convaincus les uns les autres qu'il nous
faut faire des gestes mais les jeunes
eux je pense ont évidemment un autre
regard
parce que quand on a vécu réchauffement
climatique depuis tout petit plus
kryskow vide
je pense qu'on a toutes les capacités
pour innover pour innover comme on
l'appelle le monde le monde d'après mais
notre responsabilité à nous c'est
certainement de porter des politiques
publiques mais c'est de les amener sur
ce chemin de l'enthousiasmé est pâle et
pas le chemin de l'inquiétude
donc il faut pas aller au pas les
éclater faut pas les séparer il faut il
faut vraiment faire communauté j'ai
république
je suis vraiment désolé je suis obligé
de vous laisser je vous remercie et je
vous remercie infiniment toute façon
l'émission va pas tarder à se terminer
merci infiniment michel buisson et je
remercie aussi sophie primas qui doit
qui a été de nous quitter aussi en cours
d'eau 4 nerfs et donc justement michel
buisson parler de grigny c'était d'une
des premières cités éducative et y avoir
une cité éducative à chanteloup les
vignes
là aussi c'est une forme aussi de
d'espoir parce qu'il n'ya pas bonnes à
la situation est difficile et les
lourdais les noirs mais il ya quand même
des petits des petits rayons d'espoir ah
oui lorsqu'on faisait michelle wie sol
est très important si nous adultes nous
on n'arrive pas à avoir un peu d'
enthousiasme pour pour dire à nos jeunes
que il y a un espoir qui est un chemin
et qu'ils auront chacun leur propre
chemin
je pense que la société va effectivement
être désespéré et désespérant
l'acide éducatif c'est ça c'est aussi un
intersport et c'est en plus un espoir
pour le maire que je suis mais pas
seulement que ça commence à prendre
parce qu'on a on a quelques mois voire
quelques années derrière nous maintenant
c'est une nouvelle façon de travailler
ensemble est d'abord un objectif commun
c'était travailler tous pour le pour
l'avenir de chaque jeune
et ces jeux vous dire assez
enthousiasmant de voir justement comment
les murs se sont effondrés entre les
différentes institutions
même si tout n'est pas parfait on est
d'accord mais comment actuellement entre
les parents le périscolaire la
communauté éducative la communauté et
l'état local et les différents acteurs
associatifs comment en fait il arrive à
construire ensemble un projet qui est un
projet de réussite de chaque enfant avec
sept principes communs c'est que chaque
enfant en lui des choses extraordinaires
alentours des compétences qu'il faut
découvrir qu'il faut creuser qu'il faut
mettre en exergue et c'est ces attitudes
éducatives c'est vraiment ici comme
ailleurs même si toutes les cités sont
différents c'est vraiment l'occasion de
partager d'une façon complètement
différent moi honnêtement je n'ai jamais
vécu ce décloisonnement de travailler de
bonne volonté comme on le vit depuis
quelques mois
chanteau éducative merci beaucoup à près
de rennes où jean philippe acensi vous
aussi vous voilà il ya quand même
justement c'est ce vivre ensemble que
vous facilitez avec le sport est d'aller
chercher les qualités de chacun oui je
trouve intéressant là tout ce qui a été
dit là sur l'idée de l'enthousiasmé et
c'est je pense qu'il ya une partie de de
la future élite française qui est dans
nos quartiers et je pense que ça doit
nous permettre de réfléchir un peu sur
la sur la composition des des deux
satellites
cette élite aller sur le toit du monde
dans le sport faut considérer que la
france sera un tout petit pays dans le
sport sur le champ les quartiers c'est
la moitié de l'équipe de france de
football
c'est maintenant la moitié de l'équipe
de france de rugby c'est la même chose
sur le monde
donc on a des talents incroyables
reconnu dans le monde entier dans le
sport on va pas nous faire croire que ça
ne peut pas exister dans d'autres champs
donc il faut donner les moyens
il faut donner les moyens à ce qui est
ce genre de passerelles monsieur besson
elle disait qu'il ya énormément
d'innovation le département qui créent
le plus d'entreprises c'est la seine
saint denis
donc il faut vraiment considérer s'est
délité et amp est partout en mettent à
la fois dans les grandes entreprises
dans les cabinets ministériels dans les
préfectures
il faut de la diversité dans tous ces c
est ce pas cela et c'est vrai que le
sport a une place extrêmement importante
le sport ce n'est pas que du haut niveau
c'est aussi une grande école pour chacun
chacun d'entre nous merci beaucoup jean
philippe acensi arthur donnent le mot de
la fin justement oui donc ses espoirs
justement avec la jeunesse avec ses
quartiers dont tous voilà qui soit à la
fois défavorisés de seine saint denis
c'est typique c'est à la fois de
créateurs vraiment de ce que les indiens
jean philippe acensi dans le sport
effectivement grâce à la jeunesse des
quartiers il ya des médailles françaises
mais c'est vrai aussi dans la culture
tiers que le aujourd'hui le rap français
c'est que tout le monde en écoute c'est
complètement entré dans le dans le dans
les dents là dans la culture nationale
et c'est écouter partout partout pas
seulement dans les pays francophones
parce que c'est déjà ça c'est déjà une
bonne chose mais mais partout et et et
au delà de ça il ya des choses qui sont
moins connus mais par exemple voyez le
disciplines comme la danse hip hop comme
le breakdance par exemple ça c'est bien
c'est que j'ai pratiqué il se trouve
montpon peu redouté mais j'ai pratiqué
ça pendant dix ans à la mjc de
sartrouville qui est donc la ville en
face de deux maisons laffitte bombe à
l'aigu trois grandes nations du monde
dans cette discipline là c'est les
etats-unis la corée la france la france
a lancé dans le monde dont il ya des
espoirs et des réussites et des dons
faits au combat merci infiniment
arte aux dames merci infiniment 4
hainard et nous en fait d'une personne
si michel buisson et sophie primas voit
là bas il ya une situation difficile et
puis hier aussi quelques quelques
espoirs et c'est bien des
à souligner la très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de poche
[Musique]